hello and welcome back so in this
chapter we're going to talk about how to
add leaderboards to your game a lot of
what you're going to see is actually
fairly similar to the process for adding
achievements to your game so hopefully
we'll be able to go a little faster in
this lesson and get some leaderboards
added pretty quickly we're going to
follow the same format as we did last
time by adding in a button to view all
of our leader boards before we actually
go and create any so let's do that by
going into our game view controller nib
file and oops sorry not our game view
controller our intro view controller nib
file and there we can see our button to
view our achievements let's go in and
let's add another button over on this
side and we'll call this one
leaderboards fix our auto sizing and go
to the bottom here and that over there
we go alright Wow perfect that is a
beautiful button and just like with our
achievements let's hook it up to got em
file here so we're going to move over
here let's hide this get some room here
oh my gosh scoot this over alright so
first thing we want to do is control
drag up here so we have our iboutlet
call it view leaderboards button alright
so we can disable this as needed and
let's say how about above our
achievement stuff we're gonna have a
pragma mark view achievements and then
we can add another one bads few
leaderboards
and we will add an action here which
will be leader boards button was pressed
and let's just take this full screen
there we go and now in this method
basically we're just going to create a
leaderboards controller and set the
delegate to ourselves and present it
this should look very similar to the
methods we have right above now i'm
going to call gpg leaderboards
controller notice by the way we have
both a leaderboard controller and a
leaderboards controller with an S the
leaderboard controller this thing here
is what you would use if you want to
bring up the scores for an individual
leaderboard the leaderboards controller
starts by showing you all the possible
leaderboards for this game I'm going to
start by adding an a leaderboards
controller and we'll get to that other
one later on in the chapter but we'll
just say leads controller equals gpg
leaderboards controller alloc init 30 we
will set our delegate to self and now we
can present view controller leads
controller animated yes completion
handler no great we're getting warning
that we're setting or delegate to self
without declaring that we are a
leaderboards controller delegate so we
can do that right here
leaderboards controller delegate there
we go and now we get a warning that we
haven't implemented the required method
leaderboards view controller didn't
finish so let's add that will do it
right under here there we go
leaderboards new controller did finish
and basically we'll just dismiss view
controller animated yes completion nil
perfect oh wait maybe not so perfect I
see I made a mistake here I declared a
delegate to self and what I really want
is a leader boards delegate sorry about
that all right there we go now that
warnings gone away alright let's do one
more thing here let's go down and we'll
also set our self dot view leaderboards
button hidden also is not signed in and
all right and uh gosh I think that's all
we need to do so let's run this alright
welcome back we're signed in let's view
our leader boards bring up our
leaderboards controller that is totally
empty because we don't have any leader
boards in our game well that's boring so
we'll say we're done goes away and
congratulations we've put a blank view
controller on our screen so next step
let's create a few leaderboards and we
will do that in the next lesson see you
soon
haha